What I want you to get out of this,
this lecture is what are the
questions that can be asked?
What are the things that you
can demand, um, you know, uh,
scientists and,
and folks associated with chemicals to,
to investigate or report.
So when we're doing an analysis,
you need to say, hold it.
I know that this is going to affect
molecular design and why isn't Xyz being
done? Okay? So when we
talking about hazard,
we're talking about physical
hazards, global hazards, um,
plant and animal toxicity and eco hazards.
Uh,
we're going to focus a lot on toxicity,
but not exclusively.
And so we're going to look at,
uh,
some of these strategies going
from the types of hazards,
understanding of mechanism to
the physical chemical properties,
all the way to the framework.
This is a construct to think about,
um,
the molecular design.
So when you start looking at the various
strategies that you can take from
molecular design, we think about
the, the base of the pyramid.
And at the base of the Pyramid of,
I'm sorry,
I should say that it runs from toxical
kinetics to toxic. Oh, dynamics.
Toxical.
Uh,
kinetics those things that allow
the molecules into the body,
a toxicant dynamics,
the reactions and interactions that take
place once the molecules in the body.
It's a good way to distinguish that.
And that goes up in this direction
at the foundation of the pyramid from
molecular design in many ways
your most powerful tools.
I right down here.
The other good thing about this is there
also your conceptually easiest tools.
So we're going to get into levels
of complexity up here that are
extremely challenging, scientifically,
extremely challenging scientifically.
And there are things that I don't
necessarily problems he necessarily being
solved in the next decade or more.
There's a lot of research up here
that is tremendously complex.
But the good news is just because you
can't do everything doesn't mean that you
can't do anything.
And so as we talk through these,
I want folks to be thinking about,
oh,
but people are saying that, that this copy
down and that can't be done. It's true.
There's a lot that's unknown and there's
a lot the copy done. What I want you to,
uh,
to know is that there's a
tremendous amount that is
known scientifically and can
be done today and is being done today.
Okay?
So when we take a look at these,
these various strategies
at the base of the pyramid,
we got that increasing complexity
as I was, as I was talking about.
But let's go right to,
um, uh, to some of these,
these properties that we can manipulate.
Um,
so right down here,
molecular weight,
are chemists able to control
molecular weight? Yeah.
Why do you care about molecular weight?
Going to be a lot harder to absorb.
It's going to be a harder to absorb.
Throw a membranes. All right,
so we go to solubility.
Um,
so we have molecular way solubility.
Again,
why do we care about solubility?
So there are different things. Um,
is it going to build up in our bodies?
Is it going to cross a our membranes?
Why would we care about
volatility? Uh, what's a,
what's something that's particularly
volatile that we're concerned about?
Being in our air?
CFCS makes us it's way all the way up
to a stratosphere electronic charge.
When when something is
charged, it's um, to,
if something has a charge
to it, it's going to, uh,
whether it's in the biosphere,
it might bind to particular particles
like humic acid and also it was going to
have uh, uh, usually greater difficulty
crossing biological membranes.
All right,
so molecular weight,
we know that with a molecular
weight of greater than a thousand,
you're going to have
essentially no skin transport.
We know that with a molecular
weight of greater than 500,
you don't what to have essentially no
one transport. It gets into your lungs.
It con transport across your lung.
And with a molecular
weight of greater than 300,
you're going to have essentially
no GI tract transport.
So that's, that's really important. Um,
because from where we started,
no ability to get into your body,
no ability to cause adverse consequence.
So volatility. So, um,
so we say that if something has a vapor
pressure of less than 10 to the minus,
I'll go here,
tend to the minus three.
There's not going to be
atmospheric dispersion,
not going to get the kind of
atmospheric contamination.
If you have 10 to the minus six store,
you're not going to have a,
essentially any inhalation, uh,
to that, uh, substance and
Ian, any inhalation risk
10 to the minus eight tour,
you're going to have almost no potential
for reaching the lower flammability
limit. Okay? So you
start asking questions,
how do I make this substance
maintain whatever function it has,
but I want to make sure that it doesn't
get dispersed in the atmosphere.
I want to make sure that it
doesn't get respired by my workers.
I want to make sure that it never has
the possibility of bursting into flames.
Uh,
these are some of the guidelines
that are able to be derived.